let me ask you about 2020 dad who do you  think your Democratic opponent will be  Joe Biden says he'll make a decision by  January I dream about Biden that's a  dream look Joe Biden ran three times he  never got more than 1% and President  Obama took him out of the garbage heap  and everybody was shocked that he did I  I'd love to have it be Biden I think I'd  like to have any one of those people  that we're talking about you know  there's probably the group of seven or  eight right now I'd really like to I'd  like to run against any one of them but  Biden never by himself could never do  anything President Obama took him made  him vice president and he was fine but  you go back and look at how he succeeded  in running when he ran two or three  times I don't think he ever break broke  one he was at the one or less level 1%  or less level